If you're a Nintendo fan, you don't want a
Super NES Classic Edition console.
You NEED a Super NES Classic Edition Console.
From bona fide classics like Super Mario World
to the never-before released Star Fox 2, the
Super NES Classic is going to be the must-have
product of 2017 when it officially launches
in September.
While most stores sold out of Super NES Classic
pre-orders pretty much immediately, it's not
quite time to panic — yet.
You can still get a Super NES Classic.
It's just going to take a lot of time, attention,
and patience — or a lot of money.
Your choice.
Heading to eBay
The most reliable way to get a Super NES Classic
is to buy one from scalpers on eBay.
Just be warned: it's going to cost you.
Consider how 2016's limited edition NES Classic,
which was manufactured in even smaller quantities
than the Super NES Classic, retailed at $60.
Officially, it sold out everywhere.
But savvy buyers turned to eBay to sell off
their extra consoles — and ticked up the
price tag to three or four times the original
asking price.
Judging by the few Super NES Classics already
listed on eBay, it looks like that trend is
going to continue.
As of the making of this video, prices fall
between $200 and $350, which is a mint higher
than the MSRP of 80 bucks.
A price hike like that feels almost like an
assault.
"Yeah.
That's what happens, man.
That's what happens."
But since everyone wants this console, sellers
are going to milk you for every buck they
can.
If you do decide to go the eBay route, here's
some advice: Look closely at the photos and
make sure that you're getting an actual Super
NES Classic.
Between customized consoles meant to imitate
the official Nintendo product and straight-up
fraudulent listings, with a little close inspection
you'll be able to tell the difference between
the new mini-console with pre-loaded games
and some imposter version.
Amazon third-party sellers
You can also try to buy a Super NES Classic
from one of Amazon's third-party merchants.
As with eBay, these are individuals or small
companies who got their hands on a Super NES
Classic and decided to resell it, usually
at a marked-up price.
The Super NES Classic isn't listed yet on
Amazon's partner stores, but it should be
once the console comes out on September 29,
2017.
As with eBay, make sure that you're getting
the right product.
If it somehow says "games not included," it's
a no-go, because this thing should include:
"Over 20 awesome games."
Also, try to stick to merchants with high
ratings and lots of reviews.
Hey, you might even get free shipping thrown
in on the deal.
Run, don't walk, to GameStop
If you live in a relatively remote area, check
out your local GameStop.
While the company sold out of Super NES Classics
online almost immediately, the brick and mortar
stores accepted pre-orders too.
The catch was that you just had to go to the
store in person.
By now, most GameStops in major urban areas
have probably burned through their pre-order
allotments, but areas that are less densely
populated might still have a few pre-order
slots open.
Once again, however, be prepared to pay a
little more than Super NES Classic's $80 asking
price.
GameStop knows that the mini console is a
hot item, and some customers say that they
had to buy pricier bundles with other merchandise
to get their pre-orders in.
Monitor the web
If you want to know when more Super NES Classic
units become available, keep your Twitter
feed open at all times.
When the first round of pre-orders went live,
journalists, publications, and gaming personalities
quickly let their followers know right away.
If someone beat you to the punch, that's probably
why.
Twitter feeds devoted exclusively to video
game deals also helped spread the news.
If more pre-orders become available, or if
extra copies arrive on release day, those
same accounts will probably let you know ASAP.
Of course, if you look away from Twitter for
a mere second, you risk missing the opportunity
to score a pre-order, so you should probably
only rely on this technique if you're already
a social media addict.
"Did you see the memo about this?"
Same goes for those stock-tracking websites.
Sites like NowInStock.net routinely update
to let readers know if and when more pre-orders
become available, so refresh, refresh, and
refresh again.
Don't give up
Even if you didn't score a pre-order, you
might be able to get a Super NES Classic in
stores when it officially releases on September
29th.
"Never give up.
Trust your instincts."
Toys R Us, for example, says that it won't
have any online pre-orders for the machine,
while GameStop promises that it'll have a
few units available for walk-ins on launch
day, too.
If you do decide that an in-person purchase
is your strategy of choice, just make sure
to get to the store early.
Very, very early.
Especially if you live in a big city, you
won't be the only person there, and most stores
tend to handle big releases like this on a
first-come, first-served basis.
Import a copy
This won't work if you want to be one of the
very first people to own a Super NES Classic,
but if you're in a pinch, you can always try
to import a console from overseas.
For example, while the NES Classic is sold
out in the United States, you can still pick
up a Nintendo Classic Mini Famicom — the
Japanese edition of the device — from the
popular international retailer Play-Asia.
You will be making some sacrifices, of course.
If your desire for a Super NES Classic hinges
on nostalgia, keep in mind that you'll be
getting a version modeled on the Japanese
edition of the Super NES, which looks different
than the American version.
Think outside the box
Everyone is checking big outlets like GameStop,
Best Buy, and Walmart for the Super NES Classic,
but that's not the only place you'll be able
to buy one.
ThinkGeek, purveyor of nerd-related novelty
items,
offered a handful of Super NES Classic bundles
that lasted a little bit longer than the other
options.
Meanwhile, B&H Photo and Video, which mainly
focuses on camera equipment, offered a few
consoles as well.
Once the Super NES Classic comes out, don't
forget to check off-the-wall brick and mortar
stores, either.
Last year, the NES Classic appeared at Urban
Outfitters, which is primarily a clothing
store for hipsters with money.
If there's any kind of shop nearby that dabbles
in cool and trendy tech, or appeals to those
on the cutting edge of style, it might be
worth asking the cashier or manager if they're
going to have the Super NES Classic in stock.
"What?
You never told me that before."
It's a long shot, but who knows?
You might strike hidden gold.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!